but first up he's a columnist for the
hill and the chairman of the American
Conservative Union I know you are all
members please welcome please welcome
Matt slap thank you how you doing thank
you for being here thank you to be there
well I that I really want to thank you
for being here I mean I have I have been
in your position where you have to come
to a place yet where the audience is not
with you it is not with that church so I
leave now I think I did good huh no you
did good all right but yeah but I so
let's try to talk in a way not because I
know were from different sides of the
aisle you're a trump supporter I am NOT
and start with what we agree with uh I
think you would agree that you're not
blind to why a lot of people are
freaking out about him right no great
see we're starting all right okay okay
and that's because for example the Time
magazine came out today I read it okay
and the next title was is truth dead
right and that's because of him that
we're asking that question do you think
that that's fair that we asked that
question because of Donald Trump I think
everything's fair and I think you I
think with people who fear Donald Trump
want to know is you know is he full of a
little [ __ ] sometimes and a little
bit of hype or is there something else
there that you're worried about a little
more and I would say as a trump
supporter that I actually think it is
part of someone who has not been
involved in politics who's come into the
system has had amazing success in a very
short period of time no yes yes what
success well he became the president
that's okay he had political success
political success that's different
yes he fooled people oh yes okay
all right looks like
three weeks to the up let me read let me
read with the Wall Street Journal not
exactly a liberal publication said if
President Trump announces that North
Korea launched a missile that landed
within a hundred miles of Hawaii would
most Americans believe him we're not
sure which speak to the damage that he's
done to the presidency with his endless
stream of exaggerations evidence for
accusations and plausible denials and
other falsehoods look I think everyone
should ask him to tough questions and
hold him to account for what he says but
Dean of events has done that you think
he's a liar on a scale we have never
seen no I don't honest really he ran
against somebody who was a liar on the
scale we I really do I think I think
that one of the reasons Donald Trump is
president is because the Clintons didn't
really ring true with a lot of people
you have to agree to that I'm talking
about a scale we've never seen before
I'm talking about a different scale like
I see three million people who don't
exist I I think President Obama
wiretapped me when even Republicans have
come out and said that's [ __ ] you
don't think that's a different level of
lying I think that when it comes on the
wiretapping charge quite honestly
there's no evidence for it so isn't that
a different level of lying I think that
that was quite an extraordinary tweet is
it a different level and they're
investigating it now I'll tell you this
if they find only gating it they are
they're investing is a bipartisan
investigation grant okay and the FBI is
investigating look it bill if they find
that there's no proof for what he said
then that's that's if they see this is
the damage
I think he's doing to this country the
fact that he says something and then we
all have to scramble not we all your
team right has to scramble to pretend
that the Mad King actually saw 12 would
bunny on the lawn
that you have I mean what we saw was
this guy Devin Nunez now he's head of
he's the chairman of the Intelligence
Committee this was always bipartisan
this was the one place where bipartisan
reigned because we have a great country
in the sense that the intelligence
agencies they're not just there on their
own they have to share their information
but we were smart we said not the whole
Congress because they can't keep the
secret can't okay but they got to tell
somebody that's right so it's the
Intelligence Committee right six or
eight people he's head of that okay so
this week he ran over the White House
with some [ __ ] that was a nothing
burger that Trump's name came up on
incidental collection not what Trump
said that he was wired that's right and
it probably wouldn't have if he didn't
have Putin on speed dial but can I just
bring up this in today were tapping
Russians that's what they do and his
name came up this is legal business as
normal and he went over there to give
Trump cover see this is what I'm talking
about the fabric of democracy little
tears the Intelligence Committee which
was something that was bipartisan now we
[ __ ] that up now we ruined that and I
know a little I don't think we'd ruined
it well I think there we haven't done it
a lot of help they're going to come out
with a report it'll be a bipartisan
report and the FBI is going to come out
with findings as well and maybe we can
go back to Dearest maybe an area here
that we do agree on which is all of this
incidental surveillance and all of this
they call it you know just the common
ordinary thing where they pick up
conversations I'm troubled by that I
wasn't always troubled by that I'm more
troubled by that as I see how extensive
this is I don't think it's appropriate
that they just pick up someone's
conversation we talk about a wiretap
they actually don't a wiretapping is is
a very specialized thing but the
surveillance that goes on by our
intelligence agencies is too broad you
loved it when Bush was president okay
but but that oh it's much broader now we
know this technology you know and yet
everywhere if we want to have that
discussion about whether the spy agency
should be doing it we can but that's not
what this was about let's not pretend it
is we're trying to have an agreement on
but we do it beyond that what we agree
that it should be looked at and it
should be they should go after narrow
targets and by the way but unless those
targets or members of the Trump team
that had inappropriate contact with
Russia I'm absolutely fine with them
being investigated I think if they
didn't do anything wrong they want their
names cleared but if they did something
wrong
okay the American people should know but
there is a okay I'm just saying there is
a problem when the president says some
batshit thing that he does because of
his ego you would admit he's an egoist
right in ego mainly as a healthy ego
health nut I'm sorry
and I usually react I'll use mine what
about a narcissist
everyone in politics is a narcissist a
penis okay another on every how about a
guy who will never admit he's wrong is
he that well okay so let's go through
presidents admitting that the wrong do
presidents tend to admit a lot the wrong
I've seen every president do it give me
the give me an example what about when
did Obama in but he was wrong Oh
Bhama admitted he was wrong when he said
I if you want to keep your doctor you
you can have your okay okay that's right
and why do you apologize for that yes
and it's where I mean everybody has a
level of humility they must see that
this guy is different and if he isn't
exactly new to see I do I do a nominated
tweets is what he says it's wrong and if
the tweets turned out to be wrong but he
oughta have the character to apologize
and I say wait to this investigation is
consulted combing let's get to that part
of the week yeah that was all way all
the way back on Monday yes yes when the
FBI director was out there and he said
yeah we've been looking into collusion
yeah between the Trump team and Russia's
in its July so and then CNN reports
there actually is collusion Adam Schiff
who is their Democrat on the
Intelligence Committee said this was a
change this week he said yes it's not
just we're looking for it we have it now
I heard if there is such a thing as
collusion that's treason and impeachable
would you agree with credibly serious
especially is it treason it's about the
worst thing I've heard of I don't know
what the meeting wiping Lively
my goodness I think it's probably
treasonous you know I'm not durable well
I bet you if it was a Democrat it would
be definitely treats it look I'm
guessing if it was Hillary still there
would be no probably in there I'm just
getting let me use my words here
I think Vladimir Putin a terrible thug I
think that we have a huge problem with
him I don't want to go to war with him
but I am worried about what he is doing
I think he surveilled and tries to
influence this country in every way he
can I think he did try to get hack our
elections and I think if anybody
involved in the Trump campaign was
involved in that I think that is about
the most serious crime you could commit
well that would be a treason the most
serious crime whatever K so we say
freeze okay let's wait until there's
okay I imagine we're not arguing about
that are we saying that we and adultery
because that is what the FBI director
says he's doing that's right I'm okay
doing it okay great so if it is it's
treason and you would say that that's
impeachable terrible well that is the
entire bold white man be impeached it's
a lot of happy you just jumped it down
from Philly Richmond I'm just saying if
I'm saying if someone commits this crime
it's treason yeah that's in beautiful it
treason I think you should be impeached
all of that Oh
[Applause]
it just gets water here yes well
actually we we switched it on darrell
Issa a few weeks ago but that's a
different story
all right last question because
healthcare went on this week okay the
deal maker in charge who was the
greatest deal maker couldn't get it done
are you talking about Paul Ryan I'm
talking about what Paul Ryan didn't even
understand what insurance is but that's
another sir okay so let me take I know
you're I know what your argument is and
the dishes side to it which is look
people in this country are too indulged
they're too entitled they get too much
from the government I would even agree
with that and by the way that some white
people do that's true
some white people concerned about eggs
and Trump supporters yeah yeah okay so
that's what you know when I we see what
the freedom caucus wanted to cut you're
like well that's that's pretty yeah it's
pretty rough stuff you know you're
you're cutting emergency room visits and
stuff like that but their view is look
this is a product like any other and you
know you should be able to offend your
own way but then you are going to have
to take responsibility for the fact that
it just did fast people would die you're
okay with that to make that point that
people should be on there I'm not okay
with the idea that people dying no but I
think that it would have been smart to
get the process started by passing
something in the house and coming up
with an alternative look we've been
running around the country for seven
years saying that we have an Obamacare
alternative and when it doesn't pass the
house it's like hard to say you have an
Obamacare alternative poteete
so I would I would like to get started
right but
do you watch any other shows with
newsChannel decide [ __ ] I'm just asking
I'm not doing snarky no I'm on MSNBC and
ci energy Luger is all right okay but do
you watch it yes because like every day
that I watch Chris Matthews they have
people on Town Hall at town hall
meetings and the theme the games over
and over again is the people standing up
and saying to the congressman if you do
this you know I will die and you can
tell they're being real I will die yeah
look this is the reason why health care
is about the most difficult public
policy thing to ever get done Hillary
Clinton tried it it's tough because if
someone's like hey say that someone's
life is let me try to go here okay so
the fact is is this do we have to have
an alternative absolutely you can't run
around and just be against things you
have to talk about what you're for and I
think one of the reasons why Obamacare
was a problem politically for the
Democrats and as you know they did do a
lot of losing over the course of the
last eight years and one of the central
reasons did you believe polling is
because people were dissatisfied with
Obamacare it wasn't a bunch of rich
people it was working-class people who
saw their premiums go up and they didn't
see their health care getting better
they felt like the guys who were working
felt like they were paying for other
people they weren't you're right both
sides were disingenuous about this I
said it last week on our show the
Democrats should have owned the fact
this is wealth redistribution it is
millionaires paid more so poor people
could live and a lot of mental qualities
horrible a lot of middle class people
paid more a lot of middle-class people
pay yeah some
that true and that's why they thought it
as they voted but Trump said today he
said you've all heard my speeches
I never said repeal and replace within
sixty four days here's what he said
you're going to end up with great health
care for a fraction of the price that's
going to take place immediately
okay immediately fast quick he's a
[ __ ] liar wait but I've just read it
he said fraction of the cost
great health care immediately okay today
he said I never said it would take place
within sixty four days how is that not a
lie okay so Tom price has been confirmed
to be the Secretary of HHS Tom price was
that not a long because because the
person he picked to be the Secretary of
HHS can make big changes in the health
care system this is true you know that
Kathleen Sebelius a lot of Obamacare
went through but he said and obviously
that is going to have severely he what I
hear layers all during that he met that
the bill would pass it and nearly be
implemented immediately okay thank you
I tried barrel I tried to can I'm gonna
keep trying
you're not a bad guy all right smash
laughs heaven my hand it can't easy